Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
80 % des personnes souffrant
de la faim dans le monde
sont des paysans.
En France, en 50 ans,
on a perdu plus
de quatre paysans sur cinq.
Une véritable casse sociale.
Le taux de suicide des agriculteurs
est de 40% supérieur
à la moyenne de la population.
En France toujours,
on perd des terres agricoles
avec l’artificialisation des sols
au rythme d’un terrain de foot
toutes les sept minutes.
Des chiffres pour vous expliquer
la tragédie du monde agricole,
je peux vous en citer plein,
mais vous pourrez les découvrir dans des
films, des documentaires, des conférences.
Et malgré cette réalité
qui s’impose à nous,
moi, je voulais vous dire que
je suis un paysan heureux.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Pourtant, au départ, je n’avais pas
imaginé mener cette vie-là.
Mon père, éleveur de volailles
industrielles, répétait sans cesse :
« Les garçons,
ne faites jamais ce métier. »
On a connu plus stimulant
pour créer une vocation.
Alors j’ai fait des études d’ingénieur,
en agriculture justement, pour comprendre.
Comprendre comment on produit,
comprendre comment faire
pour que sur cette planète,
tout le monde puisse manger à sa faim.
Parce que depuis toujours,
moi, j’aime manger.
Mon parcours en agriculture a été semé
de quelques désillusions.
En 2004, je pars aux États-Unis,
dans le nord Dakota, pour un an.
Le bastion mondial du maïs et du soja.
J’y vais pour me faire
ma propre opinion sur les OGM,
vous savez, les organismes
génétiquement modifiés,
et pour répondre à la question suivante :
ces innovations technologiques
et génétiques
sont-elles une solution
à la faim dans le monde ?
Ma réponse est claire, c’est non, elles
servent surtout des intérêts financiers.
Ma première désillusion.
Ensuite, en 2006, toujours armé
de ma grande naïveté, je pars au Brésil.
Là, pour faire une étude
pour les exportateurs de blé français.
Au même moment, je découvre
le mouvement des paysans sans terre
qui explose dans le pays.
Je comprends que non seulement le commerce
international ne nourrit pas le monde,
mais qu’en plus les paysans
producteurs d’alimentation
peinent eux-mêmes à se nourrir,
faute d’accès au foncier.
Deuxième désillusion.
De 2009 à 2011, ma femme et moi
partons à Madagascar,
dans un village où tous ont de quoi manger
grâce à la production locale.
Ailleurs dans le pays,
la population meurt de faim.
Madagascar, un pays
autrefois autonome en riz,
qui aujourd’hui dépend des importations.
Comment une situation pareille
est-elle possible ?
En fait, les terres et l’alimentation
sont considérées comme les
autres valeurs marchandes.
C'est un non-sens.
Pire, ça va à l’encontre
de la Déclaration Universelle
des Droits de l’Homme.
La terre, bien commun,
mérite, selon moi, d’appartenir
au plus grand nombre.
Ces désillusions, loin de me désemparer,
ont ancré en moi l’idée
que je devais envisager
l’agriculture autrement.
Il est temps que j’explique
comment je me suis organisé
pour être un paysan heureux.
En fait, j’ai fait le choix de
l’autonomie, sur la ferme.
J’élève une trentaine de vaches,
60 cochons de races locales
donc parfaitement adaptés au territoire.
Les animaux vivent en plein air.
Les vaches pâturent de l’herbe
ou mangent du foin pour faire du lait.
Et les cochons, un mélange de céréales
et les sous-produits
de la transformation laitière.
C'est hyper simple.
En clair, je n’ai rien inventé.
Sauf qu’avec notre système,
où on produit tout sur place,
cela nous rend indépendant
vis à vis des fluctuations de prix
des marchés internationaux.
Avec la crise qu’on connaît actuellement
sur les matières premières agricoles,
notre système a vraiment du sens.
Ensuite, j’ai fait le choix
de l’interconnexion
pour éviter l’isolement et
le cloisonnement entre les mondes,
l’entre soi qu’on a tous tendance
à cultiver
dans nos différents corps de métier.
Nous sur la ferme,
on est quatre paysans associés.
Ça permet de l'entraide, des échanges,
un partage des responsabilités.
On partage le lieu avec deux artisans
qui eux, travaillent dans le textile,
dans le filage de la laine.
Moi, j’adore les rencontres,
alors on accueille régulièrement
des stagiaires, des woofers,
on organise des événements culturels
sur la ferme.
On garde le contact avec les consommateurs
puisque nos productions
de yaourts, fromages ou charcuteries
sont vendues en circuit court,
à la ferme ou sur les marchés.
J’aurais pu en rester là.
Sauf que j’avais besoin de trouver
un statut juridique
qui colle à mes envies.
J’ai fait appel aux citoyens
pour constituer
une SCI agricole et citoyenne.
Un statut juridique donc,
Société Civile Immobilière,
composée de 180 personnes
de tous âges, sexes, nationalités,
catégories sociales.
Ces personnes possèdent
une ou plusieurs parts
dans la structure qui possède aujourd’hui
les terres et les bâtiments de la ferme.
En tant que locataire,
occupant,
je paye un loyer et
un fermage chaque année,
qui est redistribué aux différents
porteurs de parts sous forme d’intérêts.
Ces personnes, impliquées dans notre
ferme, qui est également la leur,
me soutiennent par leur engagement.
Ils viennent y faire leurs courses.
Ils prennent de mes nouvelles.
Ou viennent s’y promener
en famille, entre amis,
pour découvrir notre superbe territoire.
On est très loin de l’agribashing,
le prétendu conflit entre
les agriculteurs et les consommateurs.
Moi, ma réalité est tout autre.
Je suis un paysan heureux
parce que je vis en accord
avec mes valeurs.
Je considère que les terres
sont un bien commun.
Donc, avec la propriété
collective et citoyenne,
on arrive à éviter
que la terre soit source de spéculation
de génération en génération
et soit à la main de quelques-uns,
instances privées comme publiques
tout aussi obsolètes
les unes que les autres.
Selon moi, garder le contact entre
les agriculteurs et les agrimangeurs,
fait vraiment partie de la solution.
Je suis très impliqué dans
le projet de la ferme.
Et pour autant,
je me sens tout à fait libre.
Libre de faire évoluer la ferme
si mes envies changent.
Libre car sans contrainte vis-à-vis
des financeurs ou des fournisseurs.
Libre de changer de vie
dans un an, cinq ans ou dix ans.
Enfin, je suis un paysan heureux
parce que je vis dans un cadre naturel
qui offre des conditions de vie
incroyables à ma famille, à mes enfants.
Je vis à la fois dedans et dehors.
J’ai cinq semaines de vacances.
Je me rémunère correctement.
Je mange des bons produits
que je fabrique.
J’ai la satisfaction
de nourrir mes voisins
en me levant tous les matins.
Alors oui, la situation
de l’agriculture est dramatique,
mais il n’y a pas de fatalité.
Il y a des solutions pratiques
à mettre en œuvre.
Notre planète a besoin
de ces terres agricoles.
Notre pays a plus que jamais besoin
de nouvelles paysannes
et de nouveaux paysans,
nécessaires pour notre
alimentation à tous.
Alors si, comme moi, vous y êtes sensible,
je vous invite à consommer bio et local
et à devenir copropriétaire d’une SCI
agricole et citoyenne près de chez vous.
Vous verrez, qu’en plus d’utiliser votre
pouvoir de responsabilité alimentaire,
vous ferez des paysans heureux.
Et croyez-moi, ce bonheur,
c’est contagieux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)